here now administrators Seema Varma she
is a member of the white house
coronavirus task force administrative
Irma thank you it's good to have you
here tonight my pleasure
how are we doing on these tests I
remember last week I believe Alex is our
the HHS secretary said that there would
be millions of them out there by the end
of the week has that happened you know
our focus is on making sure that people
that need tests can get tests and so one
of the things that's already available
is that at every public health
laboratory across the nation these tests
are available what we're working on now
is to increase the capacity in the
private healthcare system because most
of us when we go get tests we don't go
to a public health lab you're used to
going to your doctor's office they order
the tests and that usually is handled
through our private health care system
and so we've been working with the
private system to essentially ramp up so
we can make sure that those tests are
available so is it true that there are
millions of those is it's now almost the
end of the week so has that mark been
met that we heard about from secretary
is there because I was at a doctor for
something else the other morning and
asked and they said you know we can't
get him we've been calling we called the
state we called here we can't we can't
get our hands on them and then I heard
it from another doctor earlier today
with the same story with a patient that
she wanted to test and she tried to get
a test for that patient and was unable
to do so well today one of the things
that we did dr. Hahn and I hosted a call
with over 1600 representatives from
hospitals to work with them around how
they can do the testing inside their
Hospital laboratories the other thing
that we're focused on is preparing the
entire healthcare system some of the
conversations that we've been having
with hospitals is making sure that they
have the guidance that they need so one
of the things that we did just last week
was give some more guidance around
emergency rooms and what they need to do
so I think we're seeing emergency rooms
across the nation's setting up different
screening sites so that they can screen
people for the coronavirus on the front
end those individuals don't have to come
into the emergency room the other piece
that we're focusing on is infection
control we want to make sure that people
don't pick up the corona virus when
they're in a healthcare facility so
we've asked for all of the healthcare
institutions across America to double
down on infection control practices okay
but in terms of actual equipped
we heard Bernie Sanders today for one
coming out and saying that there's a
major shortage of ICU units we've heard
that there's a shortage of ventilators
even swabs and equipment for the actual
tests what's being done about that and
how concerned are you that when when we
these numbers do start to rise which
doctor fowey has told us to expect that
there'll be enough ICU units enough
ventilators to help the people who do
get sick in this country well that's why
we have an emergency prepared system you
know we were used to dealing with
disasters if we look at some of the
disasters that have happened around
hurricanes in Puerto Rico in Florida
there is a system in place to make sure
that folks that are on the front lines
have the equipment and the supplies that
they need are you saying that we do have
we're doing at CMS is to have rapid
dialogue with health care providers so
we're meeting with providers almost on a
daily basis to understand what
challenges are they facing and what can
we do at the government level to support
them and help them and that's why we've
been putting out so much guidance it's
based on these dialogues that we've been
having with the health care community
about the needs that they have yeah
thing that we've really more challenge
though they're being not sure that
people understand hey before you go into
your doctor's office you can call your
doctor on the phone and have a
discussion with them and they can tell
you whether you need to come in or not
and that's really important because we
don't want to have people how to travel
unnecessarily if they're not feeling
well no absent if they if they come into
a healthcare facility they could also be
putting others at risk and so we're
encouraging people to call their doctor
in advance we're making sure that that
providers can use tell telehealth and
telemedicine right to serve their papers
may at that point hear quite quite a bit
and I think it's a very important point
to make but before you let you go I want
to ask you one more time are there gonna
be people in this country who don't get
a ventilator if they need one are you
concerned that the actual physical
equipment that is needed to serve the
people who will get sick is out there
can you reassure everyone tonight that
there is not a shortage of ventilators
or ICU units and that's why the
president has taken such a bold and
decisive action right we're not waiting
for this to get worse we're not waiting
for this to be a crisis in our health
care systems and that's why the
mitigation strategies that
he announced last night limiting travel
from Europe not allowing that you know
we've given travel advisories on cruise
ships that's why we're taking all of
this action because we don't want to put
stress on the healthcare system okay I
had that that's not a direct answer to
the question but it sounds like a hope
that there won't be enough sick people
and we won't run that one right out
ventilators because we have mitigated
and we certainly hope that we certainly
hope that's the case
administrator Verma thank you thank you